courtney cox will be there for you
in fact she's here to bring you some
major friends nostalgia
do you want me to cry is that what you
want
do you want to see me cry no seriously
it's so good it might just make you cry
i was so excited
on wednesday court who played monica
geller on the hit 90s sitcom
hit up instagram to bless us with her
piano cover of the friends theme song
yes have you seen it you know the one
yeah that one
the 56 year old actress played the track
by the rembrandt
while musician joel taylor strummed
along on the guitar
and a lyrical track of the song played
in the background
i mean she even had the clap down
she crushed that i know in the caption
courtney asked how'd i do i might have
said that
uh court we all voted and it's unanimous
you did great so great that the official
verified friends account
swooped into the comments to respond
with what else
clapping emojis
that's me david beckham also gave court
his praise with not one
but two omgs oh my
mariska hargitay said the whole thing
was awesome
while beth bears called it amazing oh my
god
and queer eyes tan france gave it a big
old yes
our feeling exactly court oh my god of
course
but this isn't the first time the
actress has lifted our spirits with a
little friend's
throwback if you don't believe me please
be my guest
back in november courtney reenacted a
scene from the classic
thanksgiving episode
yeah the one where she dances with a
turkey on her head
since i'm the symbol of thanksgiving
here you go i hope it makes you happy
and guys she may have made that look
easy but in another behind-the-scenes
look at the making of that instapost
she proved it was not
on oh it does hurt that thing that bone
hurts
it does it really hurts i don't know
okay it's so disgusting
hey wait what's not right about it
everything of course
quartz videos are only getting friends
fans more excited for the upcoming
reunion on hbo max
matthew perry tweeted in november that
the highly anticipated special will be
airing in march
2021 but that has yet to be officially
confirmed
so for now this will just have to tie us
over
you